تطورات متسارعه تشهدها باكستان عنوان هذه
التطورات اعتقال ومحاكمه رئيس الوزراء
الباكستانيه السابق عمران خان امام
المحكمه العليا التي اوصت بالافراج عنه
بعد امتثاله اليوم معتبره اي المحكمه
العليا بباكستان اعتقال جهاز مكافحه
الفساد لعمران خان امرا خاطئا رئيس
الوزراء الباكستاني السابق قال في
الافادته للمحكمه العليا انه جرى اختطافهم
من محكمه اسلام اباد مؤكدا تعرضه للضرب
اثناء اعتقاله وطلبت السلطات الباكستانيه
المحكمه العليا وعمران خان بمطالبه انصاره
البقاء سلميين والتنديد باعمال الشغب فيما
تواجه البلاد اضطرابات واسعه في الشوارع
وشهد هنا مشاهدينا انصار عمران خان يرقصون
قرب مبنى المحكمه احتفالا بقرار الافراج
عنه الا انه ميزال قيد الاعتقال لدى
السلطات الباكستانيه طبعا السلطات
الباكستانيه واجهت شغب واحتجاجات انصار
خان بمزيد من الاعتقالات بصفوف المحتاجين
وايضا قاده بحزب رئيس الوزراء السابق هذه
الاحتجاجات تسببت كما نرى هنا بالصور
اضرار وحرائق في الممتلكات العامه وخاصه
من بين هذه الممتلكات مبنى لازاعه للاذاعه
الباكستانيه ومراكز للشرطه ومركبات حكوميه
وخاصه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات